"The McKinsey Way reveals McKinsey's
closely guarded management techniques
towards that, we'll
have anyone at any level
think like a McKinsey consultant."
Hi there, my name is Heinrich,
and welcome to another coffee
break with Firm Learning,
Hope you're all doing well,
today we have a very
exciting topic for you,
and this is them McKinsey Way.
Many people seem to believe that McKinsey
is an organization so
unique and so special
that they have a very special
way of how they handle things
and the label The McKinsey Way
is the way to put it in a concise term.
And this belief got
popularized by one book.
by the book that is
called exactly like this,
It's called The McKinsey
Way, written by Ethan Rasiel.
Now, I hope that I
pronounce this correctly,
but this guy apparently
was a former McKinsey consultant himself,
wrote this book, claiming
to reveal all the secrets
about what McKinsey is all about.
So I remember purchasing this book
when I was a young business student,
and thinking about
whether I wanted to join
a consulting firm after university.
And I found intriguing and
interesting to read about
what a company like McKinsey is all about
and how they're actually working
in their day to day operations.
After I then joined the firm,
I kind of forgot about this book,
but I recently found it again
by accident at my bookshelf.
So, I thought it would be funny to go over
some of the key claims of the book,
of what your author
claims the McKinsey way
is supposed to be all about,
and I already give you my perspective
from having worked at McKinsey
for roughly six years,
whether what he writes
is actually true or not.
So, let's jointly
scrutinize The McKinsey Way.
Let's jointly deep dive into
it and think about whether
it's actually true, what
the author describes
as the McKinsey way, or
whether it's just complete BS.
As always, if you find this
video interesting or helpful,
please press the light button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and subscribe to the channel and also hit
the notification bed to stay
up to date with my content,
I will release at least
one video every week,
and sometimes even more as I'm
doing this video right now,
and it's not a Saturday
when you will see it
as the release date.
And if you haven't done it yet,
also check out my Instagram,
I'm posting several pieces of content
on my Instagram channel every day.
My Instagram handle as
well is Firm Learning.
So, back to The McKinsey Way.
And what I would do now
is, because I obviously
cannot go over every single
statement with you here,
because this would just take too long,
I will pick a couple of
paragraphs which I believe
might be especially interesting for you,
and I would word in this
way, that I will read to you
what he is writing, and
then I give you my brief
and candid comment,
whether I believe it is accurate or not.
And please, also let me
know below in the comments
whether you'll find
this format interesting,
because if you do, I could
also imagine continuing
with this and going over
more passages in the book
because there are many
more interesting things
he writes about that I could
possibly cover in this video.
If you are interested
to read the full book
by yourself, I have included
an Amazon affiliate link below
in the video description.
Early on in the book he talks about
how at McKinsey problems
are being structured,
so let's hear what he has to say
about how to structure problems.
"Feel free to be MECE, to
structure your thinking
"when solving business problems
or anything for that matter.
"You must be complete while
avoiding confusion and overlap."
A good structure for every
problem that you want to solve
at McKinsey is for sure
something that is very important.
MECE is a principle that is
frequently used at McKinsey.
Though I will claim that
many other consultancies
use it as way.
MECE stands for mutually exclusive
and collectively
exhaustive, and it describes
the way how you should structure problems.
Specifically, it gives you
a rule how you should divide
a problem into smaller components.
And by following the MECE
principle, the divided components
should on the one hand
be mutually exclusive.
This means that the
components should not overlap.
Every single individual
component should stand for itself
and not overlap with other components.
And second, it should be
collectively exhaustive.
So this means that, taking
all the components together
should again form the
fully completed problem.
I will insert your picture of a circle
that is divided in a
MECE way from Wikipedia,
and I hope that this helps you understand
on a more intuitive level
what a MECE separation of a problem is.
In the book, he also makes
references to the famous
and dreaded up-or-out principle.
"Associates who perform poorly,
"didn't last very long at the firm,
"after one bad engagement,
"no EM or ED would want them on the team."
For the uninitiated of you,
what does up-or-out actually mean?
Up-or-out is a principle
that is applied by McKinsey
but also other consulting
firms, which basically means
that either you get designated
over time to the next level,
or if you do not make the promotion,
if you do not make the designation,
then at some point you will
be asked to leave the firm.
So, it's either you go up or you go out.
And how exactly this
works probably is material
for a whole other video, but
what I can already tell you
is that it is much less cruel and horrible
than what it may be sounds like,
and especially in the lower levels,
if you're business analyst,
associate, senior associate.
These things are true, but
there's only a very small portion
of associates is actually
affected by that.
So, there's definitely
no need to be afraid
that for every little error that you make,
at some point you will be just
asked to leave the company,
this is not how it works.
And what I especially disagree with
is that the author claims that basically
after only one bad engagement,
after only one problematic project,
where you for whatever
reason weren't really able
to perform in the way that you hope to,
you would already be on
your way out of the firm,
this is just not true.
From what I have learned,
also talking to many other associates,
almost every single associate will be able
to tell you one story or
two about this one project
that really went badly,
about this one situation
where they really made
this crazy, insane mistake.
These things happen, these
things happen to everybody,
and trust me that everybody
would get another chance at the firm.
People would try to help you,
will try to work with you.
And if there are any specific
things that you struggle with,
people will try to help you,
they will really work
hard together with you
to really enable you to
be successful in the firm
and master this cues
that you need to master
in order to become a good
and effective consultant.
So, claiming that after one bad project,
your career at McKinsey is
over, is just blatantly wrong,
this is not how it is.
And now way further elaborating
how McKinsey solves problems,
he talks about the so
called initial hypothesis.
"Solve the problem at the first meeting
"The initial hypothesis,
"solving a complex problem,
"is like embarking on a long journey.
"The initial hypothesis is
your problem solving map."
Yes, the book is right here.
What is referred to as
an initial hypothesis,
is often also called the
day one answer at McKinsey,
the day one answer.
So, if you are a project lead
or a partner at McKinsey,
and you start on a project,
often you're asked to develop
an hypothesis, what the answer
to the problem should be
that you're solving,
on the very first day.
So very often, in the
very first team meeting,
and the very first problem solving session
that the team has, the
team tries to come up
with a day one answer.
So with their best understanding,
their best hypothesis
based on all the information
and facts they know on day one
is what the answer to a
problem should look like.
And the reason why this is
done is that this gives now
the whole team a direction.
So, based on the day one
answer, and all the team starts
to break it down into
different hypotheses.
So, what do you need to believe?
What do you need to know
in order to understand
whether this hypothesis,
this day one answer
is actually true?
And then the team starts to go out,
interview people in the
organization, collect data,
conduct analysis, and to find out
whether the day one hypothesis
is actually true or not.
And very frequently in the
process after a few days
or maybe also a couple of
weeks, you find out that,
well no, the day one
answer is not correct.
But actually one of the
hypothesis that the day one answer
was based on was found to be false,
because you did some interviews,
you conducted analysis,
and this is what the reside of that is.
So, now you can revise the
day one answer that you have
based on the new findings, and
then use this revised version
to conduct further
tests, further analysis,
and then we iterate on this answer
until you get to the final answer
that everybody believes in.
And there are many different reasons
why this hypothesis
driven top down approach
to problem solving is
actually advantageous
compared to other problem
solving solutions.
And if you're interested to learn more,
I have created a whole course
on creating slide presentations in the way
the top management
consulting firms do that.
And this course, I have a whole section
on structuring presentations,
creating storylines,
and also solving problems
in an hypothesis driven way.
So, if you're interested to
learn more about this course,
I included a link to it below
individually description.
The are over 10,000 students
already taking the course,
have a look to see
whether this is something
that might interest you as well.
He continues to argue that
why there are similarities
between business problems,
the clients are all different,
and this makes it necessary
for McKinsey consultants
structure completely different solutions
for every single client.
"Every client is unique,
"but that there are many similarities
"between business problems,
"does not mean that similar
problems have similar solutions.
"You have to validate your
initial hypothesis or your gut
"with fact based analysis.
"This will put you in
a much better position
"to get your ideas accepted."
I believe that this section
of the book tries to address
a frequently phrased criticism
of consulting in general,
and maybe also McKinsey in specific,
which is that consulting firms develop
a solution once for one client,
and then they take the solution
and said the very same solution
to a whole bunch of other clients.
And I would argue that this
is true for some aspects,
but wrong for most of the other aspects.
What do I mean by that?
It is true that consulting firms
try to come up with
methodologies and tools
that they can use not only at one client,
but then at other clients as well.
And by doing that, it really enables them
to validate their concept
to then also refine
these tools based on the learnings
that they had using them at
other client's situations,
and coming up with a solution
that is really helpful
and really adding value to the client.
So yes, this is true,
this is what consulting firms are doing.
And one example could
be a certain framework
of how the consulting firm analyzes
the digitalization strategy of a company.
So potentially, they could
come up with a framework
of saying that there are five key areas
that they would want to
look at when they assess
the digitalization
strategy of the company,
and then each area probably
consists of other elements
that they would want to look at.
And by following this
approach, they would be able
to come to a reliable and
repeatable reside of an assessment
of how good, how valid and how suitable
the digitalization strategy
is, for a specific company.
So, yes, why they would
reuse this framework
for several other clients,
what they will not do,
is just to copy paste the solution
that they found for one client.
So, it's absolutely true and crucial
that every single situation is different.
Even if you look at companies
in the very same industry,
operating in the very same
field, these companies
are often structured in
a very different way.
They operate in a different
way, there are often
some fine and important nuances
in the product portfolio,
and you need to take all
of this into consideration
to come to a solution, so
you just cannot copy paste
the solution that you just
developed at another client,
and I've really never seen this happen
during my time at McKinsey.
To the contrary, there is a
very strong spirit in the firm
trying to challenge each member
of the team to really get
to the best possible
solution for our client,
to really seek out all
avenues, all resources
that the firm has available
to get to the solution
that solved the problem for the client
in the very best way possible.
One thing many people
are afraid of especially
when they think of the
MBB consulting firms,
so, McKinsey BCG or
Bain, are the work hours.
And in this regard he
tries to give one advice.
"Make one day a week off limits.
"Pick a day, most people
take Saturday or Sunday,
"and tell your boss and
yourself that you never work
"on the day unless it's
an absolute emergency.
"Most bosses, at least in my experience,
"will respect that most of the time."
So, this is where strongly
disagree with the book,
here the author makes it
sound like that on Saturdays.
and Sundays, it is a regular
practice that has an associate
or a consultant at McKinsey,
you would need to work.
From my experience, this
is absolutely wrong.
While it is no secret
that the work life balance
at McKinsey and also
other consulting firms
is not necessarily great,
and why there are also
differences country by country,
I was part of the German
office at McKinsey,
and the German office is
considered one of the worst offices
worldwide regarding the working hours.
I guess Germans just have the reputation
of working long hours, and
having worked in Germany,
I can tell you that in
my time at McKinsey,
there were really only
a handful of weekends
where I needed to work,
because there was really
a hard business reason.
And actually I found
the contrary to be true,
in the firm there's a strong culture
to keep the weekends free.
I have seen many project
leads who really tried
to make an effort that whenever
they sense that an associate
fields like, you know, needs
to work on the weekend,
to help him reprioritize his work,
just sit together with
them to make it possible
to just cancel out all the to dos,
to help him to get the weekend free
and not making work necessary.
So, if there is just a
situation in your project
to just makes it absolutely
necessary to work on a weekend,
then yes, you will be asked
to work on the weekend
and it will be expected
from you that you will make
the time to do that.
But this is, at least from my experience
having been part of
McKinsey for six years,
this is a clear exception
and not the norm.
Now I'm interested in your
opinion, what do you guys think?
Do you also have a notion in mind
what the McKinsey way
you're supposed to be?
If you have any questions, just
let me know in the comments,
and also let me know what you thought
on the paragraphs in the book,
would very much appreciate
your opinion on these topics.
And again, if you took any
value out of this video,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to the
channel to stay up to date
with all the content that I'm planning
to put out in the next weeks and months.
And also follow me on Instagram
for daily Firm Learning updates.
It was a pleasure for me
doing this video for you,
and I'm really grateful that
all of you are joining me here
on my YouTube journey.
So, thanks so much for
watching, and have a good day.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.